working with shaylen was amazing she's
one of the best intern actresses around
right now it's not be best so working
with her is a total pleasure and she's
amazing online nightmare so that's all
good in terms of how the movie and the
story has impacted my life I think and
also impacted my life the same as its
impacted everyone had touched by this
story which is it makes you think about
actually being appreciative just for
what you have in front of you because
nothing is guaranteed you know any of us
could die at any minute or be there are
far Phelps stars you know in this case
you the fault in our stars in the stars
for Gus and hazel as cancer and a guy
for that reason that time is going to
eliminate you know that happens to a lot
of people in life I have to be
appreciative for what we have because
nothing is guaranteed I think people
like him so much because he does so much
for hazel and he makes such a big
sacrifice for hazel which if you read
the book to the story you know what this
high rises later
it's beautiful you know people always
love grand acts like that and it's
beautiful because Gus starts the story
wanting to make it grand act for the
world and he wants the world to love
them but later on becomes okay with just
making me rant out for one person and
being and having that deep love with one
person and that's just as important in
divergent you played Shane's brother
obviously does that make it easier to
play her on-screen lover in this film or
do you think it was no it made it it
made it easier not because we actually
played brother and sister but because we
were comfortable each other because we
got to know each other and we had an
on-set demeanor already we became my
friends so then when we went to Fault in
Our Stars we were friendly I mean very
more very friendly we were very close
and we were comfortable with each other
I was never it was actually probably
less than funny things yeah there's less
awkward that we had already played a
role together because then when it came
down to things I'd like to love seeing
we would comfort with each other and we
knew we were just friends and you know
we knew there was nothing else there and
that you know once they said cut we were
just friends and and now that was really
important in us being comfortable with
each other well we have a different
director Robert when he and he's he's
great
I think he wants to make a little bit of
a darker film more gritty
caleb obviously in the second film has a
much more prominent role so that's gonna
be interesting for me
they were shooting that right now and I
think it's going to be cool
you